en ce dernier jour de l'année de ville
21 nous avons décidé de venir à votre
rencontre l'objectif c'est de recueillir
vos souvenirs de l'année 2021 et de
découvrir vos voeux pour l'année 2022
pour commencer nous sommes dans le
village de maule au coeur des yvelines
c'est parti et l'or vient de rencontrer
isabelle et son fils lucas bonjour alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire vous ce
que vous retenez de cette année 2021
l'année 2021 pour nous c'était l'achat
d'un petit chef d'un petit chat d'un
petit chien pardon une petite chienne
salies voilà donc qui clôture l'année
2000 21 bleus vu récemment c'est ça
juste avant noël pour bien commencer
l'année 2022 du coup vos voeux pour
cette année 2022 ben qu'on se débarrasse
de ce foutu qu'ovide et que
ressent le match retour après plus
profiter
d'aller au restaurant librement du
cinéma sans masque mais je crois que le
masque pour le moment on ne va pas s'en
débarrasser tout cidj beau temps aussi
si possible
donc voilà pour 2000 2022 oui qu'on
arrive à bout de ses co vide eh bien
merci beaucoup merci pour vos mots
et nous sommes dans l'une des deux
boulangeries de la ville de molo avec
céline bonjour bonjour alors quels
souvenirs vous regardé de l'année 2000
20e et 21e
je garde beaucoup de positivité au
niveau des clients il avait envie de
fêter les fêtes ils ont envie de passer
à autre chose on a envie que 2022 se
passe mieux en espérant que tout se
passe bien pour tout le monde et puis
bah j'en profite pour souhaiter bonne
année à tout le monde et puis mangé de
la galette vivait parce que c'est ce
qu'il faut garder le moral parce que bas
les jours à venir vont être un peu
compliqué donc faut garder la positivité
il croire merci c'est l'une des rien et
maintenant direction neauphle-le-château
[Musique]
et nous poursuivons notre périple à
travers les yvelines pour rencontrer les
yvelinois les yvelinoises et savoir ce
qu'il souhaite pour l'année 2022 nous
sommes à neauphle-le-château un village
d'un peu plus de 3000 habitants c'est
parti on va les voir et nous avons
rencontré thomas de neauphle le château
bonjour bonjour alors quel est votre
souvenir vous de 2021 moi j'ai beaucoup
de souvenirs comme plein de gens donc si
je devais en choisir un peut-être que ce
serait celui de rénover ma maison parce
que voilà vu le contexte on a envie de
se sentir bien chez soi donc de quoi
lasser entrepris depuis quelques mois et
c'est en cours qu'est ce que vous faites
justement comme rival a par exemple on
aménage des bureaux parce que comme on
fait plus de télétravail qu'avant on en
a bien besoin et du coup vos voeux pour
2022 ça va se poursuivre suppose on veut
tout à fait de 2022 déjà battu ces
travaux aboutissent parce que c'est
quand même du gros oeuvre et puis si je
pouvais avoir un deuxième feu ce sera un
peu plus de de paix et de et de
fraternité et de bienveillance les uns
envers les autres
voilà merci thomas et nous voilà dans
l'unique boutique de mode de
neauphle-le-château avec sa responsable
carine bonjour bonjour alors avez vous
un souvenir pour 2021
beaucoup beaucoup de bienveillance et
sortir de sa zone de confort en tout cas
moi ça a été le cas pour que la boutique
survivent donc voilà être sur instagram
faire innover pour essayer de vendre en
étant fermées et puis après du coup
beaucoup de nouvelles clientes qui ont
découvert via installâmes dont beaucoup
de clients du coin mais beaucoup
d'ailleurs aussi et voilà j'ai pas eu
beaucoup de beaucoup de bienveillance et
ce qui ressortira de cette année en tout
cas pour moi et et voilà une envie de
partager de 2 autour de la mode autour
de recommencer à discuter voilà des
trucs comme ça
[Musique]
nous sommes dans le salon de coiffure de
la clé saint-pierre à elancourt avec
zara bonjour monsieur après ce que vous
avez un souvenir de l'année 2000 21 ou
partager alors laisse bon souvenir de
mêlée 21 c'est ma fille qui rentre à la
fac et que ça se passe super bien vous
avez des voeux pour 2022 les v ça masque
et vivre comme avant et c'est à la clé
saint-pierre à elancourt que se conclut
notre parcours dans les yvelines et moi
personnellement ce que je retiens de
cette année 2021 c'est lé moment partagé
avec vous ives illinois et yvelinoise 2
saint quentin en yvelines à mantes la
jolie en passant par sartrouville ou
encore rambouillet merci pour tout ce
que vous témoigner toute l'information
que vous nous donnez au quotidien et je
vous souhaite une excellente année 2022